aux conservateurs parce que je suis fan
d'amérique vous faire remarquer une
chose si je vous entends déjà monsieur
galbraith vous êtes un libéral et ça
veut dire aux états unis que vous êtes
contre les conservateurs on est de
gauche et les deux bosnie contre les
consommateurs et en france en revanche
on a l'impression que libéral c'est un
peu le synonyme de conservateurs mais
pas du tout c'est pas vrai vous avez
tout à fait raison
là nous pouvons discuter là dessus et si
vous définissez le libéral hayek
on peut dire qu'il est apte à la fois un
extrême libéral au point de vue
économique et qu'il est au point de vue
politique conservateur cela dit dans les
pays européens
ceux qui sont de gauche ou qui s'appelle
de gauche ont été et sont encore
partiellement des communistes
or moi je prétends que par rapport aux
idées libérales même celle de galles
bresse un communiste avec le pouvoir
absolu le monopole du parti
le dogmatisme idéologique c'est tout le
contraire de ce qu'il représente
alors que pourquoi est ce qu'on m'a
appelé libéral en europe parce que au
moment les gens de gauche étaient plus
ou moins des compagnons de route avec
les communistes qu'il considérait que la
vraie gauche et le mouvement de
l'histoire ça allait dans la direction
du communisme à ce moment là où moi
j'étais contre et j'avais par accident
une fois raison d'être contre
on m'appelait libéral parce que je
défends des en france la démocratie
représentative et le refus de l'économie
d'autorité centrale tels de cette
économie existe en union soviétique et
que je le pense galbraith nani repas
privé